how can you how can you even say what
those people went through they literally
grabbed everything they could carry in
and ran away from life and their homes
are done Wow this surreal devastation
this is white ash these are vehicles
burnt to a crisp this is an entire
subdivision and homes and lives gone
that was incredibly devastating to watch
that going off we turned on CNN in in
America and watch international news
broadcasting this disaster in some place
in northeastern Alberta and I know in
our backyard they're busy actually still
fighting these fires they're still very
active in town well the fire situation
in Fort McMurray is absolutely critical
right now they were simply overwhelmed
by by how quickly it spread earlier
today do you remember how you felt when
you first saw those images on the screen
being from Alberta I was definitely
feeling the devastation and feeling how
they must be feeling losing everything
and yeah I mean it's just really
heartbreaking film never quite captures
what the reality really is and how much
more terrifying it must have been for
them even the leaving for Mack a city
ravaged by flames and a community shaken
by nature but now the stars align for a
cause rebuilding what has been broken to
the power of music you are to thank for
this as well for being here for keeping
Fort McMurray top of mind for the rest
of Canada and the world
this song is long tough time slow class
we'll do the way we can lend a hand is
to say forget your troubles come here
have a cold beer forget about everything
that you got to do because we're gonna
entertainment today and I'm really proud
that I get to be a part of that to see
this on a grand scale where the whole
community is Indian music is just so
inspiring to watch fact that everybody's
so willing to lend a hand and come out
and do this concert what's that I find
that very makes me proud of my community
for us this is like why we love doing
music
part of our goal is to have success and
make the music that we love making but
so that we can affect other people's
lives in a positive way that healing
process a lot of it comes from music
tonight you will give them all a chance
to escape to feel good to know that
they're supported so thank you very very
much and they're not just giving the
gift of music these stars have helped
raise an estimated two million dollars
and you can help too by going to fire a
DCA and donate but at the end of the day
it is the brave community of Fort Mac
carrying the torch I heard it said that
one of our Berta's greatest resources
isn't an actual gas and isn't oil it's
the people of Alberta do you think a
Fort McMurray has the ability to come
back and be stronger I think that's life
I think you always go through a hard
thing and on the other side and there's
something more beautiful and something
bigger and better and I think for that
community I think it's gonna create a
special bond for them so can they rise
from the ashes without question I would
I would bet anything on that this city
will rebuild and become greater than it
then it even was before brought to you
by the brick saving you more